Mm.
Music videos are a weird art form.
They're often just a promotional add on
to a medium that works just fine on its
own.
In fact,
I think most of the time music works
better without visuals.
Videos seem to limit song somehow.
For me at least,
they closed down the possible ways I can
experience the music most of the time.
Thirty minutes later,
the feds watching it on my gosh.
Yes.
I mean you ain't getting attempts.
I'd be yelling stat in now.
Dual gram I do for content.
Lamar is new.
Video for his song element is a powerful
example of a music video actually
expanding my experience of a song rather
than collapsing it and it's got me
thinking again about what exactly makes
for compelling work in this,
in between medium watching this,
I think the answer has something to do
with collaboration.
Kendrick is known for a lot of things.
He occupies a really rarefied place in
popular culture,
celebrated for quality and integrity
pretty much across the board with a
couple of notable exceptions.
This is why I say that hip hop is that
more damaged to young African Americans
than racism in recent years,
but we'll get back to that in a little
while.
One of the things that's less talked
about is Kendrick's ability to work
seamlessly with other artists.
Of course,
collaboration is sort of a prerequisite
for hip hop.
Could rap music depends on the fusion of
lyrics and production.
Kendrick's role as a marquee artists and
hip hop is a lot like that of a film
director who acts in his own work.
He can control the lyrical content and
its delivery himself,
but it's also up to him to choose other
artists according to their strengths and
help them realize their own creativity
in the service of his vision.
Working with him throughout the process
for me was like very.
It was like being needed,
like a,
like a piece of dough,
you know?
It felt like somebody was like bending
and stretching into like,
you know.
Yeah.
Pulling different things out.
It's this kind of skill for directorial
collaboration that makes Kendrick's
music videos so strong.
To understand the element video,
you have to understand first the
collaborators in this case,
there are two,
one living and one dead.
The first is Jonas Lindstrom,
a commercial fashion photographer from
Berlin lindstrom directed the video
alongside the little homies,
which is a pseudonym for Kendrick and
Dave free.
The president of top Dawg entertainment
element is highly reminiscent of
Lindstrom previous work,
namely his short film,
truth or dare,
which features 21 performances or
vignettes and elevated version of the
content found on mobile phones.
Interested in the boundary between
photography and film.
Lindstrom is great at creating these
slow moving tableaus that serve as a
reference point for a larger environment
in element.
Kendrick has them apply that to his own,
namely to the violence that's been an
inescapable fact of that environment for
his whole life.
Violence has always been a preoccupation
of Kendrick's work.
He's examined it from every angle.
Looking at the violence that he's
endured sometimes at the hands of those
closest to him.
At this data in front of my Mama,
my comes every medic
to come us bit jummah grandma's bed,
so when a buddy brand for me,
I'm on your head.
The violence he's caused,
the violence used to oppress his race
and the violence is friends and family
visit on themselves.
Each of these facets of violence is
distilled into a photographic moments.
Some of them connect,
but they're scrambled drawing you into
this churning cycle of violence that is
the result of all these distinct images.
Kendrick can't be sure that he himself
hasn't contributed to this cycle.
He's deeply conflicted about his violent
past and about his position as wraps,
quote unquote savior.
Following the rapturous reception of his
last album to pimp a butterfly.
In many ways dam is a rebuke to that
perceived divine status and element is a
prime example of that rebuke.
Showing that he's not above hip hop's
competitive shit talking.
They just that they wouldn't go see me,
Huh?
Nigga stop decade.
That real life at the same light.
The CLTV Huh?
They just want to flex Somia P and l a
for free.
Huh?
Next time that you get the 10 freeway,
we need receipt on.
The one thing Kendrick Lamar is sure
about is that the music itself is not
the problem.
This is why I say that hip hop has done
more damage to young African Americans
than racism in recent years.
Kendrick plays the sample elsewhere on
the album.
Clearly it's something he's wrestled
with,
but for Kendrick music is a way to cope
with an understand his world,
not the cause of its ills,
and this is where his second
collaborator comes in.
Three of the shots in elephant are
direct references to the work of Gordon
Parks.
One of America's all time great photo
journalists and filmmakers.
Parks was the first prominent commercial
photographer to capture the black
experience for a nationwide audience is
focused on the inner cities for life
magazine was hugely important during
that period,
and the power of his photography is that
it forces people to see what would
otherwise remain invisible to them.
Parks was heralded for his ability to
get close to his subjects,
to earn their trust so that he could
eliminate the intimate truths of their
lives.
I'll give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give up.
Don't give up.
Don't give a fuck
by citing parks.
Kendrick aligns their artistic goals he
liked parks,
commits to depicting the realities of
his community with clear eyes,
even if that means depicting himself as
the product of a violent culture or a
violent country or sometimes as someone
who perpetuates those things.
I'm not a big fan of music videos,
but the way Kendrick brings the visions
of Lindstrom and parks into sync with
his own,
his masterful the result of the
collaboration is a music video that
operates a lot more like a poem that
connects the song and the album's
content with more touchstones,
not less element is a video that lets
you look into Kendrick's world and in
the end for a brief terrifying moment,
forces you to see through its eyes.
Got It,
got the,
made it look sexy.
My element by element.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
Casper mattresses.
There is a mattress in this box right
now.
It's actually a really cool sponsorship
for us because we needed a new mattress
in our bedroom and casper's are really
comfortable.
I had one when I was living in San
Francisco and I've been meaning to get
one.
Anyway,
it's a foam mattress that comes
delivered in a box just like this,
and when you open it,
it expands into the size.
In this case of a Queen Mattress,
let me show you how it works.
Okay,
so this is insanely easy.
You take the mattress out of the box
like you can see me doing right here.
You unfurl it on the bed frame and then
just remove the vacuum sealed plastic
wrap and it expands.
The mattresses are obsessively
engineered to have the ideal amount of
firmness and balance and it's foam
layers.
It's super affordable because it's sold
directly to consumers.
You get free shipping and 100 day free
trial with no hassle returns.
If you're not happy,
and if you go to casper.com
and use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get $50 off the purchase of a
mattress.
Thanks for the mattress,
Casper.
I will see you guys next time.